mr speaker may i welcome the new cabinet
to their places
we have a new chancellor accepted a job
from the prime minister on wednesday
afternoon and then told him to quit on
thursday morning
a new a new northern ireland secretary
who once asked if you need a passport to
get to derry
and the new education secretary whose
junior ministers have literally been
giving the middle finger to the public
it is truly the country's loss that they
will only be in post for a few weeks
now
the prime minister must be feeling
demore puppy
since he was pushed out of office
finally he can throw off the shackles
say what he really thinks and forget
about following the rules
[Laughter]
so
does he agree
does he agree it's time to scrap the
absurd non-dom status that allows the
super-rich to dodge tax in this country
[Applause]
well i could tell i thank you very much
and uh it's perfectly true that uh i i'm
grateful for uh the ability to speak my
much i never really uh lost mr speaker
but what i'm focusing on is continuing
the government of the of the country and
as i've just told you mr speaker
tomorrow from tomorrow 326 pounds is
arriving never mind non-doms mr speaker
doms doms or non-doms i don't mind uh
with 326 pounds is arriving is arriving
in the bank accounts of 8 million of
vulnerable people
and
how can we do that because we took the
decisions uh to get the strong economy
that we currently have that i'm afraid
uh were resisted by sorry growth growth
in may at 0.5 percent mr speaker which
which they weren't expecting we have
seen as i told you performances because
620 000 more people in paid in payroll
employment than before the pandemic
began and one of the constellations of
leaving office at this particular time
mr speaker is that vacancies are at an
all-time high
yes
cut him some slack faced with an
uncertain future a mortgage-sized
decorator's bill uh
they'll be soon for somebody else's flat
i'm not surprised he's careful not to
upset any future employers
so here's an even simpler one
does he agree that offshore schemes can
pose a risk because some people use them
to avoid tax they owe here
prime minister
mr speaker i'm proud of the investment
that this country uh attracts from uh
from around the world and uh he's
talking about uh people from offshore
people investing in the uk uh absolutely
thrilled uh to see uh that we've had i
think 12 billion in tech alone uh coming
in the last in the last couple of uh
last couple of months i think if
possible mr speaker he's referring uh
not to me uh but
some of the eight brilliant candidates
who are currently buying uh for my job
let me just tell let me just tell him
that let me just tell him that any one
of them will wipe the floor with captain
captain
[Applause]
let me just say the furniture has to be
repaired and one of the members already
have one bill i'm sure he doesn't want
another prime minister any one of them
would wipe the floor with captain
crasher rooney's snooze fest
and after a few weeks time
that is exactly what they will do they
will unite around the winner and do just
that
[Applause]
he's been saying all week that he wants
revenge on those that have wronged him
here's an idea prime minister
if he
if he really wants to hit them where it
hurts he should tighten the rules on tax
avoidance
but at the very least does he agree that
anyone running to be prime minister
should declare where they and their
families have been domiciled for tax
purposes and whether they've ever been a
beneficiary of an offshore tax scheme
[Music]
[Applause]
prime minister mr sp mr speaker to to
the best of my knowledge uh everybody in
this parliament uh everybody in this
house uh pays their full whack of tax in
this country and i think that people
should members of members across the
house should be uh should be should
cease this constant vilification of each
other i think people pay their fair
share of taxes uh and i'm quite right uh
what we're doing and it's thanks to the
tax yield that we have had uh that we're
able to support the people this country
in the way uh that we are uh so so we've
been able to increase a universal credit
uh by a thousand pounds uh mr speaker uh
we're putting 326 pounds into the
from tomorrow into the bank accounts of
those uh who need it most mr speaker and
thanks to the policies we have pursued
as i have just uh told you we have
unemployment at or near record lows and
that is what council has become they are
very happy to see people languish on
benefits we believe in getting people
into good jobs and
i'm looking for one
mr speaker i'm not sure he's been
keeping up with what's happening the
last few days over the weekend the
candidates to replace him have promised
330 billion pounds in giveaways
that's that's roughly double the annual
budget for the nhs
sadly they haven't found time to explain
how they're paying for it
even though one of them's the chancellor
and another one was chancellor until a
week ago
they all backed 15 tax rises
now they're acting as if they've just
arrived from the moon saying it should
never have happened
doesn't he agree that rather than
desperately rewriting history they
should at least explain exactly where
they're getting all this cash from
prime minister actually mr speaker he's
cur he's completely right i've been
listening very i've been listening very
carefully and uh all the all the uh
commitments that i'm listening to are
very are very good we will continue
whoever is elected will continue uh to
put more police out on the street
exactly as we exactly as we promised
already at thirteen thousand five
hundred and seventy six we're gonna go
up to twenty thousand uh whoever takes
over will build he they always complain
about this but we will build the forty
new hospitals mr speaker uh and i i
asked mike
i asked my delivery unit yesterday well
they don't want it they don't like it
it's because they voted against the
funding they voted against the funding
that makes it possible mr speaker and
and they have also
just in the last in just in the last
period in which he has been in office
make extra commitments of public
spending worth 94 billion pounds which
would be thousands of pounds of extra
taxation for every family in the country
mr speaker that's the difference between
them and us
[Applause]
totally totally deluded to the bitter
end
now now
to be fair
mr alden i think that's the last time i
hear from you today i think otherwise
you might be able to buy a couple of
other people cups of tea
to be fair to the new chancellor he's at
least attempted to spell it out
he's promised tens of billions in tax
cuts and confirm
he would cut the nhs
the police
and school budgets by 20 percent of
funding
the member for stratford and gibraltar
is complaining but he said it on tv
and yesterday
yesterday he said it's simply not right
that families are seeing their bills
skyrocket and we do nothing
was the chancellor speaking on behalf of
the government prime minister when he
promised huge spending cuts and when he
said that they're doing nothing on the
cost of living crisis
prime minister no look mr speaker this
is really abs pity pitiful stuff from
the party
the party that that voted against the 39
billion pounds uh which is necessary to
pay for those 50 000 nurses which were
recruiting and we will recruit by 2024
mr speaker which is necessary to pay for
those hospitals and those doctors and
those scans and that treatment they they
don't have a leg to stand on mr speaker
and and i can tell him something else
the reason the reason we've got growth
now at uh 0.5 in may is is because we
took the tough decisions to come out of
uh lockdown on july the 19th last year
which he said was reckless but never
forget he said it was reckless we our
economy would not be strong enough now
to make the payments we are to our
fantastic nhs and they know
i really am going to miss this weekly
nonsense from him
let's
let's move on
let's move on from his current
chancellor to his former chancellor
last week he resigned accusing the prime
minister of not conducting government
properly competently or seriously
he suggested the prime minister is not
prepared to work hard or take difficult
decisions
and implied that the prime minister
cannot tell the public the truth
yesterday
he claimed his big plan
is to rebuild the economy now even the
prime minister must be impressed by that
johnsonian brassneckery
can the prime minister think of any jobs
his former chancellor may have had that
means he bears some responsibility for
an economy that he now claims is broken
prime minister
uh mr speaker i i look i think everybody
who's played a part in uh the last uh
three years has done a a remarkable job
in helping this country through very
difficult times i i just want to say tim
really uh this may mr speaker the next
leader of the of my party may be elected
by acclimation so it's possible uh this
will be our last uh our last
confrontation over this just about it's
possible so i want to thank him
i want to thank him for the style in
which he's conducted himself i think
it'd be fair to say he's been
considerably less lethal than many other
members of this house
and i'll tell you why that is
i'll tell you why that is because he
hasn't come up
can i just say to this end of this front
bench
i expect better behavior and i'm
certainly going to get it prime minister
yeah
there's a reason for that mr speaker is
over over three years in spite of every
opportunity he's never really come up
with an idea a plan or a vision for this
for this country
and i can tell you that at the end of at
the end of three years mr speaker we got
brexit done which he voted against 48
times
we deliver the first vaccine in the
world and rolled it out past any other
european country which would never be
possibly listen to him mr speaker and we
played a decisive role in helping to
protect the people of ukraine from the
brutal invasion of vladimir putin and
helped to save ukraine mr speaker and
i'm proud to say that we are continuing
and every one of the eight candidates
will continue with the biggest ever
program of infrastructure skills and
technology across this country to level
up in a way in a way that will benefit
the constituents of every member of this
house mr speaker and it's perfectly true
it's perfectly true that i leave not at
a time of my choosing and it's
absolutely true but i am i am proud of
the fantastic teamwork that has been
involved in all of those projects both
nationally and and internationally uh mr
speaker and i'm also proud of the
leadership that i have given and i will
be leaving mr speaker
i will be leaving soon with
my head held high